[Music]
the shower in this hotel room is the
most inefficient thing that I've ever
seen in my entire life
this is very capable to create so that
the entire hotel room Wharton salon
[Music]
I know what you're thinking I just see
at a family event it's not easy
Oh we'll explain more later but honestly
iPad simply so they've had Android not
that crazy
so maybe everyone I'm back from New York
and I'm sure the reason is you click
this video is judging by the title you
want to know if I'm going to get a
Samsung s8 and something that I thought
it was quite interesting while I was at
the event I was like wow the s8 has
basically everything on my wish list
feature that I just mentioned in a
previous video let's see what those
things are no light OLED display full
screen home button on the screen and a
bunch of other things but I just want to
say something because sometimes I do
other things that aren't Apple related
and people start freaking out thinking
you know it was the worst the worst of
that that I'm going to leaving my
beloved Apple fans well I'm not don't
worry hi Maddie she got worried here you
go honey he likes to sit under my desk
while I work there you go the first
smartphone that I really had was a palm
tree oh and I got that about a year
before the first iPhone came out also I
want to show you this little gem that I
have had for quite a while I mean
remember this was called I think it was
the Nexus One and I remember getting
this I think it was like around 2010 and
it was a really big deal because it's
Google's first Nexus phone and I was
super excited being such a hardcore
Apple fan I absolutely loved trying
other things doing comparisons and
you're not being so narrow-minded that
yeah I'm a huge Apple fan but I like
other things too did you just keep that
in mind then plug this in and see if it
still works so the point of all of us
was really we're going to be talking
about Samsung I just seen you've always
had my phone that's not true look now
few years ago I got the galaxy s5 which
I actually really really liked I liked
having some with a different form factor
I like the camera next in fun zone that
I got after that was this is the galaxy
s7 edge now you guys probably remember I
bought this around the time of pokey
long though because I honestly to be
completely honest with you I wanted to
have a dedicated phone for Pokemon go
that's disgusting judge away I deserve
it
but I really really actually like this
phone I love the look of it it's super
slick the front-facing camera I love
because it has a very wide angle which
the s8 also has as well I wish though
that that would carry over to the video
because as soon as you flip over to the
video options it's not a wide angle for
the photocell are now after the f7 oh
baby the Google pixel phones one of the
things I like most about the physical
phone is it really does integrate
everything perfectly just seamlessly
with Google so pretty much your life
right here another thing that I really
liked about this was the placement of
the fingerprint sensor because I'm so
used to obviously being an iPhone fan
girl you're so used to having that
fingerprint sensor right here I think
it's a pretty good location use your
phone's unlocked the location on the
Samsung fingerprint sensor is actually
next to the camera and it's not centered
so it's kind of you gotta give out a new
one of these slide to get a chance to
play with the s8 while I was in New York
and I really did love the screen I mean
it is just it's beautiful but it looks
so good I mean it's just seamless just
absolutely I don't know it's unlike
anything I feel like that you'll ever
really see in a phone currently because
you look at it and it's just hmm
after I'm done chatting through here if
this is going to cut to some clips of
actually getting to play with the phone
and holding it but the problem is at a
super dark in the place that we were at
we didn't really get any great shots of
it but at this point you know what it
looks like everyone has made videos
about it and you get the point why have
you not turned your phone on yet I mean
I haven't turned the songs of 2011
probably Oh a little light has turned on
interesting are you gonna switch come on
now you can't don't you just you can't
ask this question how can I answer that
I don't have the phone yet well that
being said I just wanted to do a quick
little intercut Here I am currently back
from New York but now we are going to
continue this vlog back in New York an
incredible time and huge thank you to
Casey for inviting me and a bunch of
other creators out another huge thank
you to Samsung for putting on an
incredible event because I really did
get a chance to meet a lot of new
creators that I've never met before and
I had a really great
time I will see you from the road to the
plug so okay
[Music]
you
if
[Music]
Louella Frankel and I think one of the
coolest things that was actually on my
top wish list for Apple was to have the
integrated touch button on the screen
anyway right now we are going to get
lunch well let's see there's lots of
other countries here and remember good
timing
we never came from the mint how are you
yes thank you would you like to
introduce yourself to my internet
friends I'm Brad freeze and I fly
helicopters up in Canada talking Justine
and coming up and doing some stuff with
us oh my goodness and you got the cutest
dog ever Bentley so who is finders what
we just had a birthday this is the
recently yeah he if I actually
Valentine's Day oh he's a Valentine's
week dog and you guys have to see this
clickable clip because it is by far the
cutest thing that I've ever seen
[Music]
you
we're also showing me some shoddy stuff
that you filming am I looking like a
drone shot no end of the helicopter
helicopter I am using a drone a lot now
yeah now but that's like before I was
little there's the human zone so how
long you been doing it
25 years I only look amazing only in the
final one - oh yeah is the oil valet
that said what we think of all of us
like newbie drone people compared to
like you know how I wonder I like I'm
I'm not as a held up tolerance for
patrons
I love drums I might call about drove
about in cycles I the best thing for me
was that ability to dock and use it as a
computer and I think I don't know if a
lot of you are going to use it but I can
see applications is somebody who travels
you know like going to locations to do
new stuff I think that's one of the
smartest features I've ever seen
so you guys miss that that a thing
called sex it's a monster video by the
way I'm just we're just having a
conversation here there's a thing called
Dex the new s8 has and you basically can
dock your phone and then connect it to a
traditional keyboard mouse and a monitor
and you can usually get a good pathway
go the tablets it's pretty cold water in
New York if you miss that memo
yeah we're going to go to lunch now
who's all here I just basically came
here I didn't know anybody now was it
Tori I found a friend so far I've seen
what's inside Devin Supertramp Tom
there's a lot of youtubers here which is
good news because I was like I hope I
could find somebody to be my friend
today and I did yeah you're my new
friends so I hope you're having a great
time and now I wish I brought Ben Lee
[Music]
[Applause]
while you just saw the audio this work
what we said was yeah the runner is
really good like I think it's shaved
height with pop rock on top and twice
reference but we had a change of plan
we're going to be innate oh this is the
back lip but we know you're there it's
like you're very right so really what
kind of burden
oh yeah Joey McCarthy a cool in it
we're a car full of youtubers cameras
out talk of their time with the
microphone that you have is incredible
and I was like okay I can get them on
Amazon tomorrow but I want now
yeah I'm sorry you're going to go wrong
things no time like it's phantom power
it doesn't mean like horse dirty
[Music]
we've arrived forever
oh it's so beautiful so you're going to
be getting a new camera
you think yeah I'm leaving in the new SD
cards do on that one
oh my experience and then you get a
couple ends
when you order your item and then listen
your item and you cook it up over here
what what it's not the computing so
great i wanted i want you to microphone
they haven't said the switches here
until this morning but now they're sold
out allowing the mic return oh this is
good okay that comes with a wind block I
believe inside yeah yeah you probably
buy another battery too well in here now
you can do stuff how do I pick all this
up hold the camera alright pretty tough
so basically SilkAir thing for that one
oh look I felt this in the one yeah just
like whatever I have on the floor are
you yeah we just bombarded this poor guy
was like I'm sorry next request like one
of the time please and then walked away
you're using the camera that I'm
currently vlogging with and I'm getting
the UV cover of the lens that you're
going to get and it was really great and
your vlogs are now going to be just like
stepping it up yeah okay so is it going
to cut from iPhone to this one probably
that's so great but still good here's a
receipt for the items that we purchased
over here at the counter and then we go
downstairs look you know you mean a much
bigger database Mergent are you gonna do
like an unboxing or like what's up
no I don't do about I'm not cool that's
a bad thing well I'll tell you what's
inside there's a lens and there's really
high
do you think I could stay in there
I mean like how excited are you over
your new camera super excited for you I
know it will be the nicest camera I've
had fulfilling beyond my one motion
camera which is really ok yeah this one
camera that's creepy
what's your blog channel so uh it's
Brandon Baldwin vlogs but I haven't
actually got the URL yet for it ok well
it will be there well your link in the
description yeah yeah I'm a channel of
gizmo flip though so you guys tell him
to let me destroy the phone because I'm
so good at it I was staring at this
woman for the long upon this woman over
here you're taking a picture she's not
real and I would like picture of that is
impressive
Wow I'm creeped out gonna unpack
everything now it's gonna take a long
time there's a lot of traffic okay we
got the microphone so we're going to
test the audio this is my previous rode
microphone and now we're going to be
switching to go to the US with the new
microphone what are you guys saying come
on
so this is on the normal setting it's
now to try it on the low pass I want
this microphone is called low cut low
low Oh low cut which I think helps down
I don't know how I see my family member
and we have little here things to
protected the earth yeah these are he
bring his little dog look what you've
done
yes check this out look at you've gotten
anything ours have my blog or maybe this
is like this was about a party bring
others when I popped it off it's just
it's it's like a three feet up it just
hit the face down it's a little bit the
glass all over not even a good holy all
the seekers of Zelda and I'm gonna I'm
gonna play to get like crazy we were
just going through a nice cool tutorial
so I'm excited to your progress so
you'll get there you'll get there now
heading into a super fun event this is
the being posted by Katie nice dad and I
believe there's some other cool creators
this morning we saw the press event from
the Samsung store but now I don't really
know what to expect because I just don't
know
we're so close to the screen we're like
right now Wow
[Music]
and receive immunity the hearty Delta
thinks that everybody through those
[Applause]
right here Brundage thank you it's going
to be it's going to be a McDonald's food
and food escape to give me this video
clip everybody stop trying out I'm
serious yeah I'm so looking to have
ideas in there by the way oh my god my
sister all the time we preach we've met
but we never met a girl yeah and Twitter
this event was incredible hey thank you
so much for putting this on and we all
had is amazing and you oh my god so
Spike Jonze was one of the biggest
reasons I got into filmmaking I am so
excited he was able to show up for the
yeah like I'm not even kidding you but
like he and hi evan has the most the
biggest influence in getting me to get
into the summit especially with
slow-motion I am
Thank You Casey that's awesome and thank
you heliox like john hi Evan
we wave like this now I think it was our
new way alright it is a time before the
party the party party party after party
a party oh my god wait we're willing to
wear the blue girl the boom-boom room
kumkang floor all carpeting it looks
like I come together mmm interesting
cocktail bar right in the middle all
right sounds really all beautiful and
you are so just the case setting at the
high five
we gotta redo that Rena do take two all
right you ready
just watch this
that was awesome very part of my body I
couldn't think I think I'm injured sorry
the first Almighty laugh - what is that
it's a I don't know but it does one
little motion so high five oh here we go
actually found it so actually down it a
little better
well I'm exhausted we do oh I'm actually
pretty fun oh look at how nine hundred
okay let's do this nice quick draw this
one well I think